hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his discussion of justice and
Injustice within the passes it might at
first appear by looking at certain
passages that Blaze Pascal is
essentially a relativist or at least a
skeptic about our possibility of ever
really knowing what's just or unjust and
he certainly sees something to that but
he's not committed to relativism or
skepticism instead it's a more complex
matter that we can look into and so you
know where does this idea arise in
section 291 he says in the letter on
Injustice can come the Ridiculousness of
the law that the Elder gets all my
friend you were born on this side of the
mountain it is therefore just that your
elder brother gets everything and then
he follows up with another other
question why do you kill me and this
gets addressed in 294 where he goes into
a little bit more depth about that he
says that you know we would have
expected to see Justice the same
everywhere set up as he says in all the
states on Earth and in all times whereas
we see neither Justice nor Injustice
which does not change its nature with
change of climate and then he gives a
few interesting examples three degrees
of latitude reverse all jurisprudence a
Meridian decides the truth and he goes
on and says a strange Justice that is
bounded by a river so when you cross a
river from one country into another
Justice changes or truth on one side of
the Pyrenees error on the other side
what's that supposed to mean well you're
going from France to Spain or from you
know vice versa from from Spain to
France and what's legal on one side
isn't on the other side so Justice
is it seems rather you know dependent
upon where you are and it's not just by
location it's also by as he points out
time
he's got this phrase in here fundamental
law so that the laws that are actually
the complete basis right
change after a few years of possession
so you know somebody comes along takes
over a country they're going to leave
their laws in place but inevitably they
change them to different laws and and we
can see this all over the place right we
can see this even here in a pretty
unified country like the United States
where we have all of these state and
local laws and arguments about whether
they're just or unjust and something
that can be completely fair in one state
and actually required is prohibited in
another well this is this is a human
condition problem one that we see
running throughout history people don't
just argue within the same Commonwealth
or Community about what's right and
wrong just and unjust they argue from
place to place as well and sometimes
they even Pascal doesn't talk about this
there's a grasses greener on the other
side so we should be more like those
people over there and this is a really
big problem right and so he goes out and
he says you know you you would expect
like he says that the the you know the
glory of true Equity would have brought
all Nations under subjection and
legislators would not have taken as
their model the fancies and Caprice of
Persians and Germans instead of this
unchanging Justice is there some sort of
standard of unchanging Justice out there
well this is an idea that's been around
for a very long time you know maybe
there should be natural laws as he says
that would be common to every country
but then he asks
do we find anything like that
is there anything that we can point to
as a norm that is acknowledged by every
single civilization culture country that
we come across
and the answer is is no
he he goes out and he says theft incest
infanticide parasite killing your your
father right these have all had a place
among virtuous actions
so we make exceptions for all of these
and it's interesting you know that he
brings up the Persians and the Germans
because the Germans were sometimes taken
the ancient Germans as you know a good
example of how things are done
differently among those barbarous
peoples right
so you know there's good reason to think
that there aren't any absolutely
Universal norms and he says doubtless
there are natural laws
however and here's where he might be
viewed as a skeptic good reason
once corrupted corrupted all of these so
we can't even rely upon our faculty of
reason as those who often appeal to
natural law will say that we can we just
look at our inclinations and kind of
think about it a bit and it comes clear
to us that there are precepts of the
natural law and Pascal is saying
the evidence doesn't actually show that
and human beings reason is not this
infallible Oracle that some people take
it to be so that is a problem and what's
the result of this
different people different people's if
we're using uh people in a sort of
collective term they have differing
conceptions of what is actually going to
be just an unjust so he says the result
of this confusion is that people put
forth different
proposals maybe it's the authority of
the legislator we think about what the
legislators intended and we try to put
ourselves in their shoes and think about
how this should work right
maybe it's uh based on something more
present the interest of the Sovereign
the rulers at the present time and you
know we see similar problems coming up
in our own day between you know what the
law says and what the legislators
presumably had in mind if they were
actually on the right track and what the
present-day circumstances in the people
in power require in order to make things
work and then we have a third proposal
the present custom and Pascal says we
should think about this one a little bit
more
he says nothing according to reason
alone is just in itself all changes with
time custom creates the whole of equity
why for the simple reason that it is
accepted it is the mystical Foundation
of its Authority and now this raises a
predicament
if we want to inquire into this we want
to be rational human beings and think
our way to what the essence of Justice
might actually be this is what political
philosophy is it's not the only thing
it's concerned with but it's definitely
one of the fundamental concerns of this
discipline of political philosophy
if we go back to First principles as we
think we should right we we're like oh
we should like go back to the origins of
this figure out the essence and then
everything is going to be great what
happens when we do this we screw things
up
why because we erode the power of custom
he says
nothing is so faulty as the laws which
correct faults he who obeys them because
they're just obeys a Justice which is
imaginary and not the essence of law it
is quite self-contained it is Law and
nothing more whoever carries it back
authority to First principles destroys
it right and he says the opposite the
art of opposition and revolution is to
unsettle established Customs sounding
them even to their source to point out
want or lack monk of authority and
Justice so he says you know people will
come along and say we have to get back
to the Natural and fundamental laws of
the state which an unjust custom has
abolished
and notice what he says about this this
is a game certain to result in loss for
all it's not going to give us what we
want it's actually going to make things
bad for everybody it's going to erode
the power of custom in general and he
says yet people readily lend their ear
to such arguments they shake off the
Yoke as soon as they recognize it and
the great prophet by their ruin and by
those of these curious investigators
have accepted customs and he says
there's a contrary mistake sometimes
people think they can do justly
everything which is not without an
example so you know we human beings are
just a hot mess when it comes to
figuring out what it is that is
genuinely just and unjust essentially
naturally just and unjust
then he says a couple other things that
I think are very interesting and
relevant here he spends a lot of time
talking about the interplay between
Justice and power and the imagination
and how that works and then he talks
about
um Montana being wrong now Montana's the
person he quoted originally you know
truth on one side of the Pyrenees
falsity on the other and he says that
Montana's wrong why he says customs
should be followed only because it's
custom not because it's reasonable or
just this is Pascal saying that
but he also points out a problem
people follow custom for this sole
reason that they think it is just
otherwise they wouldn't follow it any
longer although it were the custom
because they will only submit to reason
or Justice custom without this he says
would pass for tyranny so you know there
are cases where we were doing things one
way and then you know we come to realize
that there isn't really Justice in the
way that we're doing it and then we're
like oh you know I get that we've been
doing things this way for a long time
but we really need to change that
because it's it's not right anymore and
now we've realized that that's really
awesome and we've made some what we take
to be moral progress
um but you know if we think that a
custom is actually right we'll be uh in
awe of it you could say and so he says
it would therefore be right to obey laws
and customs because they're laws
but we should know that there is neither
truth nor Justice to introduce into them
and that we know nothing of these and so
must follow what is accepted by this
means we would never depart from them
but people can't accept this Doctrine so
Pascal is kind of saying you're damned
if you do you're damned if you don't we
don't really know enough about Justice
and Truth to evaluate Customs well so
really we should just follow them but
once you once you let that cat out of
the bag people don't want to follow the
Customs or why the hell should we do
this sort of thing that way he says
people cannot accept this and as they
believe that truth can be found and that
it exists in law and custom they believe
them and take their Antiquity as a proof
of their truth not simply of their
Authority apart from truth thus they
obey laws but they're liable to revolt
when these are proved to be valueless
and this can be shown of all looked at
from a certain aspect so he's
introducing a fundamental problematic
here isn't he
the last thing I wanted to bring up well
what about you know actual political
Theory
he mentions and this is in section 331
Plato and Aristotle you know and you
know think about it who are among like
the acknowledged greatest political
theorists at least of the ancient world
those two guys right Plato writes the
Republic uh Pascal is actually going to
talk about a later work the laws which
is more extensive and actually much more
prescriptive than the Republic which is
sketching out this ideal uh Commonwealth
and then we've got Aristotle's politics
which is critical of both of those and
adding some New Dimensions into it and
these were you know viewed by a lot of
people this is a this is a time when
people are putting forth new political
theories they're still viewed as like
you gotta grapple with these so he says
we can only think of Plato and Aristotle
and Grand academic robes they were
honest people like others laughing with
their friends and when they diverted
themselves when they engaged in some
distraction
was writing their laws and politics they
did it as an amusement
they weren't really making serious
proposals here well they were in a way
but only in a certain way he says that
part of their life was the least
philosophic and the least serious why
because the most philosophic was to live
simply and quietly if they wrote on
politics now think about this line if
they wrote on politics
it was as if they were writing for a
lunatic asylum
right they were laying down rules for
that and it they if they presented the
appearance of speaking on a great matter
it was because they knew that the Mad
Men to whom they spoke thought that they
were Kings and Emperors they entered
into their principles in order to make
their Madness as little harmful as
possible so Plato and Aristotle not
actually putting forth proposals that we
should take completely seriously that
are going to give us the essence of
justice and Injustice more just trying
to limit the damage limit the harm by
providing certain distractions for The
Nutters in the Asylum the Kings the
Emperors the magistrates the archons the
rulers the people running the show
so this is a rather pessimistic view on
our capacity to attain and enact and
even understand what is truly just
it's not you know saying that all of
it's completely garbage Pascal thinks
that we do in fact have conceptions of
justice and Injustice it's just that if
we look at them closely we're not going
to find them holding up quite as well as
we would have liked